I am then I'm 8 years old I'm Candace
I'm Ben's mom we know everything's going
a little crazy right now in the world
with a coronavirus and like everyone
else we are doing the best we can to get
through it our kids school got shut down
about a week and a half ago and now that
makes us the teachers initially thought
it wasn't gonna be so hard but the first
day about 30 minutes into it I was
having breakdown everyone was getting
emotional we were stressed out there was
a lot of frustration so I said okay I
need a break I need to be able to wrap
my head around this stuff and one of
Ben's assignments was to write in his
journal every day so yes mom can I write
about our first homeschool day
make sure go ahead we're only 30 minutes
into it but you know whatever you want
to do
why didn't come across with it in his
notebook until a couple of days later so
I want to go ahead and add it read it to
you now it's not going good my mom is
gang stressed-out
my mom is really gang confused we took a
break so my mom can figure this stuff
out and I'm telling you is not going
good it was not going good so we're
we're happy that it brought a lot of
laughter to the world the same way that
I did us and we really appreciate you
letting us do our story with you thank
you
[Music]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going